what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to do a first time watching
for a a really high brow comedy supposedly
grown-ups today joined by my friend all the
way in the big apple salad Amanda Sally Lamonica
full of salad Sally how are you today I'm
a I'm a full salad today had some dinner stressing
on the side I don't know where it is I don't
know what's going on yeah a little tossed
today anyway um if you guys leave a like that's
the first sort of business please go ahead
and do that secondly Sally you and Adam Sandler
fan I like Adam Sandler more than a lot of
people seem to like yeah man I love Adam Sandler
so much can I fun facts yes fun fact and I'm
zooming in on the video I have like one of
those uh movie canvases where they take a
screenshot of each frame a color attached
to it and it creates this cool work of art
okay and the one behind me is actually from
The Wedding Singer oh no way and my brother
got it for me because it's my favorite rom-com
so oh I love that stand there following Sally
on her own YouTube channel she's producing
a bunch of crap lately and stop crap but she's
producing stuff yeah What The Hell she's just
producing stuff I should have left it at that
also uh full interaction watch long as we
stick it with your own copy available for
our super sexy rejects over our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined your support
means the world all right Sally you ready
to do this I am so ready I love him let's
uh let's finally watch this
this is really straightforward title credits
okay yep Adam Sandler playing basketball
shoes oh David Spade young dudes he's a ladies
man oh my God that is good that's a great
lookalike that's great casting yeah
oh my God no no [Music]
nicely done cast of stranger things
I want you to play Life just like you played
that game today so when that final buzzer
of life goes off you'll have no regrets here's
to coach [Music] this is a really fancy party
for a kid's basketball game I was gonna say
damn I graduated college I didn't even get
a dinner I do like outside on up here like
that no stop texting the nanny you know how
gross that is for a kid to Texas Nanny this
isn't good tiger what are you trying to poison
me good Lord go back to texting I I don't
I ever want to hear that out loud again what
is going on here uh wow
someone drunk oh child
man he said your friend coach buzzer went
to heaven I was trying to find heaven for
you on the Navy station so you could go visit
him that thought process I know
okay grown up of her
con your mom damn look at Kevin James just
locking
it down
that would have been so fun to film oh my
God I made the pumpkin risotto that we saw
in Rachel Ray's seasons of Summer special
it's awful Mom it tastes like roadkill Dan
do you see how they talk to me do you hear
that now you know your father works very hard
at keeping this house clean and putting three
meals on the table for us every day hello
I brought us a pizza what a [__] move
oh my God Happy Pizza you broke my heart looks
like it's his time of the month
that's not a man
see that ass is still growing got a little
Kardashian in there
it's my mother hello Mama and Sonia I'm so
pleased to meet you I'm little Lenny's wife
oh what a spicy quesadilla you got yourself
what oh didn't I tell you to turn the phone
off there Greg yeah but it's my massage therapist
what no no no cell phones wait no cell phones
and I'm out of here who's ready to get their
funeral on oh my God hey so these are your
kids and who's that girl that's not a nanny
is it oh no this is a a friend of ours from
China oh yeah no I've been on that website
[Laughter]
hey nice ears you get the NFL package on those
these guys are all mean I know it's like I
haven't seen you in a while and our coach
is dead let's just insult each other for like
five minutes it's Captain caring of the SS
melodrama oh he's gonna play this one big
thank you hey hey hey kind of crazy seeing
all these people in one movie mm-hmm I don't
make jokes at funerals because it's disrespectful
but if that's part of your healing process
I'm cool with it Ah that's nice hey are you
cool with the finger in you oh my God and
this must be your mother my wife Your Design
Line is so beautiful thank you thank you and
I love your scarves thank you she'll be tying
me up at those later oh ho ho ho that's she's
gonna pull a little hamstring no no oh that
was a long time
so you cannot pay me enough that sounded like
a real laugh like Adam Sandler was not acting
last year I understand that the Saint Mark's
team of 1978 was the only championship team
the the coach ever had Believe It or Not Robbie
and Marcus were actually shorter back in 1970.
five bucks it takes them down on one knee
you're wrong
[Music] [Applause] [Music] oh man oh Domino's
[Music] [Laughter] [Music] he just had five
dollars I was gonna say who just has five
dollars Mommy I want some milk oh sure Angel
come here give me a little something what
Jesus oh he's uh 48 months that's four we
meant to stop last year but um he likes it
so much and we don't like to say no this is
so messed up pork please no no no
looks like she didn't get the memo there's
so many fat jokes in this movie but not fly
now [Laughter]
Maria Bello though she is hot I like what
Adam Sandler produces movies for him and his
friends to hang out yeah I want to do that
he's got a dream job it'll do for one night
yeah you can handle it
daddy where's that machine I was getting rid
of the Moss honey where's it taking them hell
don't say that again I'm trying to help Mexico
Mexico
they're all all right I promise you see look
at this guy yeah he's still sleeping it's
dead dad oh a part swing I know what
bunions you know I actually have a poultice
I make using Maize just say corn maze is corn
everybody my name is
it's fantastic it's amazing [Laughter] my
Afflicted area is print oh my God oh my God
deny is it how in the world is anybody supposed
to get some sleep knowing they under the same
Rufus Toby Brian over here
I know Jesus and we used to shoot bottle rockets
at each other you always go for the guy's
face because you want to Blind them okay that's
a little much bro no no I know kids don't
do that [Laughter]
a tree baby you know what that means we get
to hang ourselves oh my gosh and that doesn't
make you want to go nuts it makes me like
I I I I you know let me show you yeah oh it
was a terrible idea yeah yeah you're right
you got to back it up back it up this is why
women live longer you can't just assume the
Rope is why would they make him go first
[Applause] Oh I thought he was gonna hit the
boulders
I gotcha
very good
oh no remember we used to come here in high
school last night
what's wasted a nice one eggy uh wasted uh
kids is something that happens when you have
a hankering for ice cream well I want to get
wasted I want to get totally wasted I want
to get wasted every single day of my life
[Laughter] getting it we can drink all we
want I'll shut it off I'm gonna have a Coke
and I know Donna she's gonna want a spray
correct sweetie and uh
yeah imagine that little kid growing up and
watching this movie being like what did I
do just get the water we're done talking about
water tap water uh I go get the boss baby
that last shot your foot was on the line shouldn't
have counted they don't look like they could
make it up and down the court anymore what
about you you put on a few pounds from when
I was 12 yes
hmm rematch I did next time you come to town
I'll have plenty of that Boss Water for your
kid Voss water by the way with a V it's it's
what is Voss water can we afford it you don't
know what Voss water is no no more sophisticated
than me Greg it's water in a glass bottle
duh we gotta go to Milan it's pretty cool
the Roxanne's got her fall line coming out
fashion week and they show boobies on Italian
TV I'm going to Italy I mean no no we all
we I didn't tell you guys we're probably gonna
go to Italy
Gloria and I are making breakfast for everybody
using a dehydrator well I'd rather be hit
by dehydrated fruit than a processed so you
think you're rich and you can just slap people
dehydrated I don't think that don't say that
[Laughter] would you like me to make an egg
white frittata Mr fader I mean is is that
what you're doing in science class that's
so stupid just let her in on it right just
tell her cooking the bacon not in here that's
dead animal flesh and it's not going near
the vegan food murderer what do I do with
it oh I know oh I'm sorry buddy I'm sorry
yes what
ew oh no oh dude
clean this thing right yeah I cleaned this
thing oh man thanks a lot by the way uh McIntyre
Island ain't close damn that [__] cooked
fast
stop oh stop ew this movie's literally just
them hanging out huh
and they got paid Millions he won at life
honestly mad respect this is like the white
people Friday I love it black guy no I had
a bad blood sugar test at my last check up
and Sally cut me off oh I got my own hidden
stash I'm not stupid I hide them under my
clothes the smell on my sweat socks mask of
the chocolate smell and and the looks of your
underwear Master chocolate stains laughs are
you peeing or as a diesel truck turning off
what the hell is that well listen to hamper
Morse code I think he's sending a message
in Morse code the good news is these girls
are gonna say hi to it no no they don't all
look like that ladies I think 300 pounds ow
[Laughter] goodbye to you friend wise advice
giver buzzer noise maker
oh come on it really messed up my marriages
it's my fault man
I'm already making it about this they're going
to be here in about 20 minutes wait what I
can use a piece of chicken I don't know
piece of crap car what is going on this movie
just looks a lot better shut up how do you
get that from that 95 of that's got to be
from the mother and I am lowballing hey Jasmine
how is that possible my old man lent me this
turd your old man yeah my boyfriend 47 years
old you know I wish I let guys my own age
but I'm just chasing the dad that ran out
on me what [Laughter]
okay Mom
I don't know but it feels right
I hope that car never gets fixed I don't think
it will took the spark plugs out nice oh my
God three of them have like the hottest wives
too like what are you doing and shift
shift
this is so messed up oh honey you blown your
gasket
[Music] [Laughter]
what at least he's getting something I've
been shut out ever since DM found out she
was pregnant oh yeah that'll happen can you
have sex when they're pregnant or does that
hurt the baby no Mackenzie can because the
baby thinks he's getting a Tootsie Roll I
can't believe we're doing this how do we always
listening
wait what are they doing like Arrow roulette
so they're just gonna shoot it up and see
like where it lands oh this is the stupidest
idea in the world yeah why women live longer
[Applause] ride with the dog be dog beer that's
awful
[Music]
ouch that looked real
no what are you doing
[Laughter]
oh
how did he fall over if it was like in the
ground oh well I've got attacked by an India
but then yeah he got away what an attack by
an Indian Daddy what happened Amber [Laughter]
yes I'm down here Daddy's hurt you got another
one yeah hey hey
so mean that's Maggie Chung she's a great
actress all we need is a pull ties with some
maze shut up are you insane get some alcohol
on this [__] you should know plenty about
that you were bored during the prohibition
there's the snap that was bigger than I thought
it was gonna be that was mean
hi this is Roxanne fader I just want to make
sure okay now your tooth yeah that's great
honey just put it under the pillow and I'll
put a dollar in there later okay listen what
Becky I'm on the phone I'll put the dollar
under oh there's no tooth fairy what is going
on in this room no matter what's happening
it's a tooth fairy Greg did you ever believe
in the tooth fairy
it's a real life moment Greg she's learning
that they have they've lost it's really important
family he made a mistake parents make mistakes
remember the time I told Greg that babies
come from Mommy's poop did you believe that
Greg they don't
didn't they say no cell phones they're not
on their cell phones
I'm dead
I'm on a SpongeBob
that's cool I never did that no no I tried
it it didn't work that well for me I was like
oh this sucks yes I have always been the Tooth
Fairy Becky so so so much okay okay come on
you're costing me a fortune
the bird is okay
[Music] Bean we have to learn how to share
even with birds
yeah what hold it like this down low and throw
it and let the rock do the magic your feet
nice oh that's great do you know how to skip
rocks Mrs fader are you kidding me I am the
best at this give me that wait
[Laughter] I forgot how to skip a rock now
I think it's gonna take a couple of days to
figure it out I think we better stay are you
kidding me to learn to skip a rock no maybe
she's not as smart as we thought yeah see
you couldn't get that in Milan oh my God hot
understanding
it's rare got them at a store called Naughty
and Nice Marcus said it was the only one that
was open the only place open for bathing suits
in the summer hi bathing suit at Stop and
Shop s
that is very peace
where did she get it hey somebody likes what
you see
what they have been [__] no I'm just kidding
I'm kidding he's got weird face is that an
eight pack put mine to work Sally wow that's
it girl
does he like Sally don't fall for that crap
you stay away from him what are you talking
about he's gay isn't he no he just seems gay
he's a genius he's a genius yes I could say
nevermind there you go who's that let's go
[Music] is it coming this way he's coming
this way he's coming towards us please go
for the granny yeah it's Gotta there's gotta
be a catch [Music] hey what's up ladies
you american ladies you put out the Saskatchewan
eh laughs [Applause] that's so mean everything
was on steroids except for his voice
I feel like that would take longer than just
waiting in life
wow this does look fun and they got to like
get paid for this too I know so because you're
two of the hottest chicks I've ever seen in
my life hey what these are my daughters right
her definitely because she's fugly just like
you who's next he deserved that for that comment
oh my God are you making it [__] you know
they put a chemical in the pool that turns
urine blue no no no it's an old it's an old
wives tale sweetie an old wives tale oh my
God you're humiliating me
uh I'm glad that's not true [Music] foreign
[Music]
wow that looks so dangerous so fun I don't
like it either good thing the kids chickened
out so you don't have to go right faded why
don't you hire somebody to do it for you
step aside Chumps
of chicken [__] isn't it that is so dangerous
yeah they don't do that anymore where the
concrete is there but oh dear sir [Applause]
go down there hang about your feet is that
safe what are you okay you're an animal why
don't you do it I got kids yeah Wiley
no no no
as long as there's a crash on the concrete
we're okay I've seen those but they're not
as dangerous
exist though okay Tim Duncan's had about a
hundred game winners with that bad boy what
are you watching me impressive how come you're
not out there playing basketball you you and
the guy you got
you got scared
he's into the Chinese girl well you're mean
to him so it was great
they've streaked so much water you can't be
passed out drunk single with no responsibility
and not pay for it I don't have to be hurt
was he gonna end up in the lake no Marcus
the bird is all better Marcus he wants to
talk to you food
how does he not laugh like I would have broken
so she's blonde well she's tall super hot
not your type me and Blondie start going at
it and you know we're shaking the bed this
picture behind right on the wall Falls and
goes hits her on the floor oh my God it's
just hurt the [__] two aspirins he gaps
on him like a frisbee dog I am tired Marcus
your snoring kept me up all night long
oh no
[Music] that is bad what's the problem
Arrow push maybe I flirted with him but that
was just to get your attention well what about
a snoring I heard it too [Laughter] well what
happened to your head when I was changing
into my PJs I got the feeling that some perv
was looking through my window so I went to
go close the shade and I tripped and hit my
head
I answer your phone it was your assistant
I asked him if he canceled the flight to Milan
and he said he did before we even came here
I'm not saying he made it up I'm thinking
in his heady he believes it's true oh no that's
messed up we got a nanny we got so she is
a nanny no no no no she's not a nanny of course
she's a nanny when does the Line stop stops
right after this she's more of an au pair
[Laughter] I enjoy having a nice conversation
with a woman that wasn't going where's this
and did you pick up that yeah well you can
have nice conversations with me when you come
home you're just you're just tired all the
time you barely even touch me or look at me
woman yeah you should have married Umberto
de Lucio like I oh my God oh my God look maybe
I do take you for granted and I'm sorry how's
about I take you out every Thursday night
for date night you know Thursday's Gray's
Anatomy but any other night would be beautiful
and with love comes hostility Rob when he
snapped at me the other day inside I was saying
do not call him a bug-eyed sociopath with
a little man complex or a [__] Filipino
Fonzie [Laughter] in life the First Act always
exciting the second act that's where the depth
comes in Word self-aware film [Laughter] I
don't know man this thing was crazy you should
be all right should be no no no
oh that looks like so much WoW let us just
hang out with our families all right we want
to relax yeah yeah they're afraid of us yeah
that's what it is we're afraid you might eat
the ball before we even start I think if the
buzzer was here I think he'd want us all to
try was that William Shatner all right let's
do this then it's on everyone heard that that's
right [Music] [Laughter] hey look that he
doesn't react just like they're all just like
oh well
foreign
[__]
oh no come on man
that was intentional uh oh I guess
[Music]
foreign
[Applause] er's real wife is that really her
yeah and I think those are his kids too
[Music]
I can't even breathe I like since the second
quarter hey you want to pick injuries you
got it okay
you can beat up the line this time please
Sky Sports [Music]
that's impressive
it's very Michael Jordan's number huh Adam
Sandler that's where Michael Jordan's number
yes [Applause] [Music] oh he needs it [Music]
[Applause] nah kick his ass [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
he gave it up he's a good man I hate that
what I hate it about cars oh wait he helped
never mind [Music]
oh my God [Music] [Applause] because in the
end it isn't about winning Greg it's about
family family gets in the way of monetary
gains the Bailey's needed to learn how to
win every once in a while and creators needed
to learn how to lose
[Music] I would be like you embarrassed us
you embarrassed this whole family of course
he's getting along for this hey man there's
one thing they'll never beat us yet what's
this
[Music] fired into the crowd yeah all right
everybody what are you doing there's children
that's so messed up that is awful
oh my God
[Music] what's that [Music]
at least it's not poop
we win again
whoa whoo
is there a post-credit scene I don't think
so they usually do bloopers though don't they
uh I don't know his movies I think this would
be the type of movie to have bloopers Jamie
Chung by the way not Maggie Jamie that's important
right before the credits pop up I wanted oh
my God was this on my crotch the whole time
I'm sorry your webcam did you notice it no
I wasn't looking at it it is Jamie oh God
I had put my like screen down it was like
on my ah you fell oh wow I uh that was embarrassing
okay I'm about to be a married man Sally I'm
sorry swimming with your crotch only fans
right now [Music] they got Rupert Gregson
Williams to do the music that is such a problem
no don't pause it play it hit play usually
it's I usually it's after the big credits
what damn okay nevermind there's nothing you
know like okay I know okay Jesus oh look it's
me wait go up it's Sally lamanna off where
Sally stroganoff right there lemon's off where
are you looking oh oh that was the character's
name ah yes yes yes yes I was in this movie
that's great I played a MILF dude my hair's
looking Wild anyway wait I have to pretend
you're here [Laughter] anyway what'd you think
salamander
um I just I love Adam Sandler I love David's
fade I felt like I just got to hang with them
for a few hours you know well the only thing
missing was like a beer I know I'm awake I
found myself kind of lost in it I felt like
I was on vacation with them like it was very
long but it was like it was a little slow
at Pirates but but it also felt like a hangout
movie like that was the point you know what
I mean it is exactly what it is there's nothing
more than that and I was kind of prepared
for that I was told it's like Adam Sandler
just hanging out with people but I wasn't
expecting it to be just I won't say for for
a movie without Like a Villain it was still
entertaining because I feel like that's hard
to do yeah it was still funny it was it was
funny and um like no it wasn't like the most
hilarious movie ever but it does feel I it
is the kind of movie I prefer watching at
home where I am able to just sit back relax
and just feel like I am on vac and notice
about like an hour in I was just here with
them on whatever random Adventure was happening
you felt like you were just hanging out with
them because there's no real plot right at
least Friday had a real plot it's sort of
there was like conflict but not plot if that
makes sense yeah I mean there's things that
have like that escalated and had a real like
wrap around to it in a character Journey for
Ice Cube and then here it was uh they wanted
to make sure their kids learned there was
more to life and ideas value in Salma Hayek
learning not to be such a a tight ass about
everything I know that there was a this is
there's more to being a parent than than work
and be honest with each other and and and
uh just love each other just no need to put
up a facade just just be real I guess there
were some nice little messages in there okay
Barney
wasn't it sometimes you gotta learn to lose
and uh I'd be giving it generous there's like
some random [__] but yeah no it's just
a fun movie about them hanging out and um
rekindling or something I don't know I had
fun watching it I don't really expect much
out of the comedies for Adam Sandler if I'm
laughing that's all that counts I'm having
a good time that's all it counts it is a massive
cast I was gonna say like the budget for this
just to like have the cast that's pretty much
what they spent the budget on and then a few
stunts you know here and there but um yeah
it was definitely like a feel-good movie you
know you're watching it and you're like smiling
the whole time so that's not bad and uh the
only like jaw-dropping moment for me where
I was like what was like the David Spade and
daughter moment for sure oh yeah it was hilarious
I mean um the movie the movie Just aims to
make you have a the movie just wants you to
have a good time and vacation with them and
laugh and and I feel like isn't this like
a terribly reviewed movie it's got it yeah
I don't think people liked it it's an Adam
Sandler movie it's the kind of movie audience
is clicking I wonder I wonder how it did box
office because I feel like this isn't the
type of movie I feel like people would like
want to paint that sounds bad like like pay
to see in theaters type movie if that makes
sense because like it's not like a cinematic
experience type movie I don't know I've heard
or do you think they would like Adam people
show up for the Adam Sandler comedies when
they're released in theaters and like he's
gotta cut that out I love Adam Sandler I'm
not hating on you no no no it stays in the
video timing yeah I hate Sally because I did
see him in theaters it's just this type of
movie is more of like a put on like hanging
out well he moved to Netflix I think for a
reason I mean other than a bunch of money
to do these exact kind of films but uh it's
um I think over I I don't know this movie
did make I mean it's Gotta Have Made money
because the you gotta see cast it got it what
yeah those are grown-ups too where they grow
up even further I have no idea what it's about
but um grown-ups they go to avoid 162 million
dollars at the domestic box office so it made
money and grown-ups too was also a hit it
it didn't fall too shy of of it so that means
audiences returned and wanted to experience
more of the grown-up Cinematic Universe but
uh yeah I think that I'm just the wrong demographic
for sure I mean I think you know this is like
2010 2013 or somewhere around that time range
of when these movies came out so I mean like
now what is this the kind of movie that would
pull in box office revenue maybe not but at
the time of Adam Sandler he couldn't really
do anything wrong back then you know right
at the time this was kind of his Peak ish
yeah and like no his comeback right because
he like had a ton of hits kind of like in
the 90s early 2000s this must have been like
a comeback movie which is probably why it
did really well because I don't remember I
don't really know the trajectory of out of
Sandler's career I feel like it's kind of
just listen I know Spanglish come on and then
yeah well we'll see I mean he had Jack and
Jill a little bit later then he had grown-ups
too a little bit after Jack and Jill um but
I think people just start feeling like he
was getting lazy and stuff but I don't know
to me to me his his Vibe has always been just
hanging out and shooting the [__] is has
always been my vibe with Adam Sandler and
I've always liked that about him and so I've
never been uh one to be like really offended
by his kind of like there are people who really
hate his comedy and I I've always liked his
I've always thought people who don't have
a sense of humor and take everything too seriously
I mean yeah they're like low brow comedy jokes
and stuff but it just feels like a guy who
just laughing with [__] on his own time
and then he's just like the fact that he got
so oh my God in this movie my God yeah I love
that he gets the famous woman the hot woman
to be his wife and he's so good for him and
I think his movies also tend to have a pretty
good heart uh too like even this movie is
as a like juvenile as it is it's still got
a heart about it they always have a good uplifting
message and it's still in a way even though
the jokes are dirty the message at the end
is still kind of like family friendly if that
makes sense yeah exactly that's what I mean
it is the heart is on display and everyone
whoever talks about Adam Sandler says how
great of a human being the guy actually is
and I feel like that shows especially with
the fact that he's always having all these
people like return to be in his films yeah
people like being with him and working with
him and I felt bad when people were making
fun of him and stuff because I'm like as an
actor like if I got to be in an Adam Sandler
movie I would consider that Peak so what's
funny is Adam Sandler's an insanely talented
dramatic actor like that's the no yeah uncut
gems insane I mean I like uncut gems funny
people yeah Punch Drunk Love Rain Over Me
yeah he's done a lot of like he's got a a
lot of a lot of great dramatic work and then
it's crazy to think like watching those movies
and then going back and watching his old SNL
days it's like night and day he has so much
range it's crazy yeah I do wish this movie
if it just had a little bit more of a of a
plot of a real plot of something of something
there of like some obstacle to overcome because
I I guess I guess there was something there
and when they were after um after Rob Schneider
thought David's debate slept with his daughter
that yeah all the truths were coming out and
I was like oh I guess I thought that yeah
there'd be like more to that yeah I guess
this was the plot of the movie that that it
was about like escaping this or something
like I'm expecting something like super deep
or anything which is something to latch on
to though I was expecting a freaking bomb
to be dropped in that moment and then everything
would change and then they would have to like
try to work it out yeah as a group but it's
fun watching a bunch of famous people get
to hang out with each other who are not doing
their top tier comedy I think the way you
said that sounded sarcastic yeah it's just
great to watch a bunch of famous people hang
out with each other his sister watching famous
people I like the famous people no I'm jealous
of them it's genius I know it's such a lifestyle
I guess I just don't know the uh I would like
I would like uh I wish one of them really
um if I'm gonna like judge this movie on a
some serious metric here I wish it had someone
really truly like shy you know everyone would
just felt like they were getting their paycheck
and just hanging yeah I want I wanted someone
to like really feel like this is like great
comedy from this performer when it really
just felt like them hanging out having a having
a good time because no one really like shines
you know they have a everyone I think David
Spade had the best moments in terms of like
making me laugh but I just loved it like his
one-liners like got me in this movie because
some of them felt like they were ad-libbed
or something because you could see other people
laughing like genuinely so I think they allowed
that I like Kevin James I like I like everyone
in here I thought they gave a lot of Spotlight
to Rob Schneider but he was like the least
funny one to me in this or was it Chris Rock
I'm not sure which one was the least funny
person Chris Rock I think is hilarious but
I think I think that's the word I'm missing
here is I feel like they could have utilized
their everyone's talents a little bit more
you know because they're all hilarious comedians
I think they're all hilarious so yeah Yeah
the more I think about it the more I'm like
I feel like some of the characters couldn't
shine because they were given kind of the
wrong role I think if that makes sense yeah
but then the wives were um and did you get
the hot wives I have no idea what Adam Sandler's
real wife looks like was that her she was
the one that I cut to and then and then uh
this little girl had the line yeah she's in
like every one of those movies I think I love
how he always puts it always makes his wives
like
someone someone asked him like in an interview
like what his wife felt about it and he said
actually his wife will like tell him on set
like you need to kiss her better like you're
not doing it right you know like she'll uh
be into it and I'm not into it but she'll
she's just touching herself no you know what
I mean um I get what you mean Greg let's just
get rich and make money or make movies with
all our friends yeah half-assed our talents
it's just so weak did you see the KFC like
was like placed perfectly in each shot that
it was in that it had the logo I was like
yeah that's how they paid for this movie genius
use of product placement I must that and the
Coke products too because Dasani and Coco's
like get it you know I mean he's got the fan
base I think I think it's the thing with Adam
Sandler fans they they like to just hang out
with him they like to just check in with him
yeah I hang out with him all the time that's
kind of just how I feel is when I watch an
abstailer movie like I just wanna I just kind
of want to kick it I don't really I don't
really give a [__] for much more than
that I will say during quarantine like it
got really dark and I remember I like binged
a bunch of his movies and it made me feel
better so I appreciate him for that yeah yeah
he's got some great ones man he's got some
great moves like Happy Madison Happy Madison
no no no but Happy Gilmore sorry that's his
belly production company yeah yeah though
I remember I watched those and I felt happy
and was like thank you Adam Sandler I even
like such mind-numbing but good have you seen
his movie with um uh uh Andy Samberg
um what's it called that's my boy have you
seen that one no that was on my list though
it's like a hard R comedy from them and I
think he's really funny in it really I think
they're I think it's a really funny movie
okay I'll have to watch it then yeah I remember
I think I started watching it but I don't
I don't remember it anyway we're done for
today Sally you can go home now okay well
can I just say he um he lived him out or he
still lives in Malibu and when I went to Malibu
High School like he would play basketball
with a bunch of local kids and stuff like
he was really cool oh okay he still does I
think and he got rejected from IHOP have you
seen that video yeah yeah I've seen that so
he's a real one we love you Adam Sandler thanks
for hanging with us because he's watching
this video you know my episode I was watching
he's always wanted to hear what people have
to say about it he loves he loves to hear
what the opinions are about him all the time
alrighty guys well you can follow Sally on
YouTube and on Instagram and uh when is this
video dropping wait not to cut you off it's
dropping the week I'm out of town so your
wedding week yeah no I'm out of town another
week March 3rd is when I'm dropping um um
why because my announcement video will be
out by then okay well go check out Sally's
announcement video and if it's not out this
stays in the video and you guys are gonna
be like what announcement video so the backup
just it's all in there it's all in here uncut
raw Primal like Sally she's a raw human being
when we do these zooms she keeps the camera
on her crotch repairs that was so my heart
sank like I looked I glanced over to like
bring my laptop up I was like it's been angled
at my crotch as a whole night I would have
said something okay good okay I would not
be uh Marco [Laughter]
you might have been dropping Clues the whole
time no I can't see you I I rely on hearing
you and trust that the zoom is going and we
could hear each other but I mainly just use
the zoom for audio I don't I don't need to
see you I'm doing the I'm watching them watching
the movie
I'm red I'm red uh it's no worries all right
guys thank you for being here we'll see you
all soon bye bye [Music]